The card you gave me the other day was an unspeakable masterpiece of the market, was
n't
it?  But I can
share my happiness with everyone with my dream
I'm happy with just that we
can hey Dealing cards without reward There are rankers too
It's Club Iris's life! It's
Blau's dream.
Part 2 Nice chubby check, etc. Fuguiruka-chan and your favorite outfit No
corner copy
Damn Sally It's just a god to create a bad card Thinking about
tonight  It's only a matter of time before Plow's dreams take
over.It's not just
celebrities.The two of Tokiwadai Junior High School's label 5 are both idol powers, but vb
4 pos.  Patty with cat ears and a tail
hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha Misaki-chan's been in a school swimsuit so far away from junior high school so fat, please
pray for my body
meow a company that fears even gods Saha sheet
label 5 is also for me  If you put
it on, you'll literally be completely naked
Oh, oh, that's good.
Wow,
only me hon, I'll give special attention to the memories of the witnesses Oh
, no, if these two team up, it's easy to commit a perfect crime